I do not want Alicia Keys around if
something goes awry your fourth of July
fireworks event
she has no help just common tastes no
I'm just fully leaning into questionably
bisexual dad mode hi my name is grease
on me feet I've known I know like it's
different now I went on Twitter - you
guys what kind of video you guys wanted
to see today and a bunch of sides true
of conciousness videos which I still
don't fully understand what you like
about them but for the small wonderful
core of you that like them this can't
imagine if you're just a person that
couldn't do like the taylors with hand
horse couldn't get it hot on got it got
it it's got it got it got it got it got
me got it it's a heart God it's just
true conscious videos where I just let
my brain wander and see where we go
fashion terrorist the way you don't feel
the press slave a little bit creatively
blocks and I cannot figure out why and
that is the most frustrating feeling I'm
sure so many of you have it now got it
or at some point in your life and it's
just super frustrating and the thing
that I do that is the worst part of all
of it is I just instead of like trying
different things to get myself out of a
wreck isolate myself in my house my
heart house and I don't do anything
other than really work on keeping my
shoulders I'm touching my ears but are
cool parts of the body isn't it bizarre
as a culture we find really sexy
something that literally just spews [ __ ]
because that's probably why Donald Trump
is our president yeah Mitchell Davis
tonight you said a whole video about
loving butts but now in this climate I
feel like it's somehow it's gonna be
offensive to talk about I think maybe
that's kind of why I'm creatively
blocked too is that I used to be in such
a rhythm a momentum of making stuff and
then you start to slow down and
second-guess yourself and as soon as
that like sputtering slowing process
happens then you just continue to pick
up the momentum over analyzing yourself
to the point that you just don't make
anything cuz
you don't know what if it's gonna be
good and your bad brain assumes that
it's gonna be bad and that too
someone's gonna find it offensive and
terrible for some reason show your bad
brain goes you did not get a date why so
just stay and watch queer I oh we're in
get up close and personal for this one I
just finished season two of queer I and
it was amazing and I'm also so mad at
myself because I finished it so fast
that now I don't have any more of it
what do I do
what do I do start the crown probably
yeah I know I know I know I know I can
like smell the smoke off your little
furious comment fingers being like how
good the crown is a little how are you
guys happy belated Father's Day I have
no idea what I'm gonna edit this video
so that applies for basically every day
of the year that isn't actually Father's
Day so I can sit on this one for a while
if I want to one of my favorite
activities sitting on things chairs
couches deadlines in VidCon is coming up
are you going oh god that was a
confusing leg ask him up this way but
didn't pick a lane like it came to the
fork of like sneeze or burp and it
really chose last minute what else is
going on in the world isn't completely
and utterly devastating and terrible
[Music]
tami Muhammad a me from cui rice episode
1 they should make Polly Pocket versions
of Tammy that we can all buy a house
children and adults that just like you
open it it's just very encouraging words
that just ah just you really feel like
you she means that I know that I'm very
clumsy but I don't know when this
happens think I just walk around my
house I just say one of the sexiest
meals you can have as an adult a bowl of
frozen Brussels sprouts
Antony from Korea I if you need a sec
I'm ready and waiting you can find me
right here at the World Cup soccer
football sorry and to both sides of the
people that hate both of those things
I'm rooting for Ronaldo pays taxes got a
general note to anyone that is there has
to pay taxes do I just you should do it
Iceland it seems like there happened to
goddamn great time so far and Messi
seems a little messy I talked about this
like I know what I'm talking about but
you know also what the [ __ ] is
Travelocity is marketing campaign the
travel I know but this is that no have
you really thought this through very
much also I just realized I don't care
my parents are coming into town and I
always panic before my parents come to
visit my dad and my stepmom are coming
to hang out they don't need me to
babysit them but I always feel I'm
guilty not spending time with them two
completely paranoid that they're gonna
find something weird in my residence and
3 the hoos is gonna eat their faces off
so here's a quick little section of my
advice for anyone that's having some
like out-of-town guests coming one hide
everything
I'd have to hide everything good in your
calendar set aside at least two hours to
make sure you go through everything and
hide all the bad stuff the stuff that
Jesus doesn't like Jesus is what I
assume your parents names
- probably going on a dog that doesn't
get along with other people or animals
those are it that's it I was gonna write
a book about it but you know I decided
to spend my wisdom in a YouTube video
instead let's see what's happening we
all go to Twitter moments no butter no I
haven't showered in a while what are
some of your vices that's my bug zapper
if anyone's wondering I got this shirt
from Nasty Gal calm because I'm like I
said filthy nasty and I like it because
it doesn't wrinkle ever no matter how
much I fold it up or pack it up I have
an entire closet of stuff I don't wear
because it gets wrinkled in the act of
fun wrinkling it is the most depressing
stream-of-consciousness when did I play
rugby and forget like I said I am kind
of a creative fun
if you guys have any tips on what you do
to get out of any sort of block or
feeling of like utter despair you know
oh it's really nothing you could do is
ever good enough those like like sweet
normal feelings let me know in the
comments down below feel like I've
talked for a bit so I might leave now
and by night I mean definitely leave now
if you guys like these kind of videos
give it a thumbs up subscribe to this
YouTube channel because it's that fun
kind of unpredictable scheduling and
content that I know you love but hit
that bow notifications so you might
possibly at some point or dove maybe get
notified when I do upload a video other
than that I don't know I have to urinate
isn't it funny to that we love
Tudor so much and they just you know
this bad stuff comes out of there okay